Who is "The Prince That Was Promised"?
No promises, but "House of the Dragon" might
finally answer that burning question.
In the wake of its series finale in May of
2019, HBO's "Game of Thrones" left a lot of
unanswered questions.
One of the most pressing was regarding one
of the show's many prophecies, which were
presented throughout the season only to be
dropped by the finale.
Among those prophecies, one of the most debated
was the one concerning the "Prince That Was
Promised," also known as the reincarnation
of legendary warrior Azor Ahai.
"Game of Thrones," through the Red Priestess
Melisandre, spends a fair amount of time bringing
up the mysterious figure, and there are any
number of possible candidates for the role,
including Jon Snow and his presumed half-sister
but actual cousin Arya Stark.
We never get an answer, though.
When the series ends, so does speculation
about this "Prince That Was Promised."
Now, the prequel series "House of the Dragon"
might have an answer in the weeks ahead.
"Before Aegon's death, the last of the Valyrian
pyromancers hid his song in the steel."
In the show's first episode, when King Viserys
decides to name his eldest child and only
daughter Rhaenyra as his official heir, he
tells her that Aegon the Conqueror predicted
a long winter that only the Targaryens could
fight — which he referred to as the "Song
of Ice and Fire."
Then, in Episode 4, Viserys shows Rhaenyra
a dagger resting in the fire with words inlaid
upon it that also refer to the "Prince That
Was Promised."
"From my blood, come the Prince That Was Promised,
and his will be the Song of Ice and Fire."
What this all means — and how it relates
to "Game of Thrones" — is definitely up
for debate.
As fans of the original books know, the word
for "prince" in High Valyrian — the language
in which the prophecy is written on that very
dagger — is gender-neutral, meaning the
term could refer to a man or a woman.
With that in mind, could Arya, who slays the
legendary Night King at the end of "Game of
Thrones," be this foretold prince?
However, this dagger seems to specify that
the prince or princess will be descended from
Aegon the Conqueror; Arya isn't, but Jon Snow
is.
To further complicate matters, the dagger
is the very same Valyrian steel dagger Arya
uses to kill the Night King.
Fans will likely never stop debating the identity
and mere existence of the "Prince That Was
Promised," and "House of the Dragon," at this
point, at least, is merely stoking the flames.
When "Game of Thrones" premiered in 2011,
it quickly became the most talked-about show
on the air, drawing huge crowds and becoming
one of the last instances of "appointment
TV" during an era increasingly populated with
on-demand streaming hits.
As its run continued year after year, the
show only gained traction, picking up major
accolades — including a whopping 59 Emmy
Awards — and gaining fans right and left.
Then, in the spring of 2019, the finale aired,
and the chatter largely ceased, as one of
the world's biggest shows lost its cultural
capital seemingly overnight, thanks to its
controversial finale.
We can go over what exactly went wrong with
"Game of Thrones," from dropped plot points
to ruined character arcs, until we're all
blue in the face, but there's no denying that
the series somehow ended with both a whimper
and a bang.
"House of the Dragon," a big bet for HBO after
the outcry over the finale and final season
of "Thrones," has paid off so far, and has
even been renewed for a second season.
And it does have a major advantage over its
predecessor in that its source material has
an endpoint clearly marked.
Original showrunners David Benioff and D.B.
Weiss had to move past George R.R.
Martin's source material to wrap up the show,
whereas Martin has already written all of
"Fire and Blood," the source material for
"House of the Dragon."
Hopefully, "House of the Dragon" won't leave
us hanging like the original did, but truly,
only time will tell.